i'm back with actress and dog lover
olivia munn also joining us now is one
of america's top
gear heads he's hosted a whole slew of
nascar shows
he's also covered the kentucky derby and
the olympics as a correspondent for nbc
sports
now he's switching gears get it as host
of the new smash hit game show floor is
lava on netflix check it out
with gerald's basketball background
netting that last leap should be no
problem
oh no houston we've got a problem
[Music]
[Music]
all right yeah well let's bring rutledge
wood on in here hey what's up rutledge
how you doing hey guys
i'm great how y'all doing hey man well
i've got olivia mine as well
i was like i'm going to keep her in
because we we both are into games and
this is awesome laura's lava is a hit so
rutledge like your show is ridiculous
but it's also insanely popular
so tell everybody how it works all right
so basically we have a gigantic
uh room filled with magic lava and
so you're probably wondering where do
you get magic lava
uh craigslist and i got a great deal on
about 80 000 gallons or so
uh and we have these insane kind of
rooms it might be a kitchen it might be
a planetarium and you basically have to
get from one side to the other
using your team and whoever can say the
fastest with the most people
wins ten thousand dollars so i know you
two love games i feel like y'all would
be
naturals at it but it's um
it is probably pretty hard i challenge
accepted rutledge
so wait olivia did you want to ask
rutledge anything about the game
anything
i i want to know like where how do you
guys come up with
the the different obstacles all the time
so i feel like that's one of the biggest
challenges how do you constantly keep it
new and fresh kind of like ninja warrior
asks right
sure yeah well i mean let's be honest
let's give credit where credit to do
without you olivia i don't think stuff
like this would exist because you re i
mean they could have called g4 olivia
but that's
really besides the point okay so that
being said
uh it was it was this incredible gal
named megan mcgrath she had this great
idea that
it said let's take this game that we all
played as kids and
try to make it fresh and fun and new
because like
um kelly's obviously in like a world's
hyper studio but like olivia when i see
your living room
i already think you're you're kind of at
an advantage you've got chairs
uh i don't know if that wall stuff could
take my weight but it might take it's
like
it's just a game that anyone could play
at home
so it was trying to make all these kind
of secret things in there and just make
it fun for everybody
yeah oh my god okay well rutledge olivia
played this game as a kid yesterday so
what house games did you play as a kid
oh now keep in mind i grew up in alabama
so like uh
our games are beautiful today yes
okay keep going you all know our our
games are like who
does anyone here own a ball you do let's
play that game so uh
we played my parents had a long hallway
and we played dodgeball
with we would take like a bunch of tube
socks and
ball them up and we would like line them
up in the center you'd run but i don't
know about y'all there's some about
being a kid and being on carpet and
having things hurled at you at a high
velocity i got hurt
way more often playing that game than i
should have but
that's what i was kind of that reminds
me of when um
the game that we play all the time as
children who didn't have money
um which was get in the blanket
everybody into a
blanket on top like all five kids the
top of the stairs that are carpeted and
then just
take it down down like a sled yes yeah
yeah you tried that i tried that in the
laundry hamper
and it went pretty good but i was just
big enough
as a kid there's about a fourth stare
down and i just sort of darted
yeah but that's you know you live and
learn that's awesome that's awesome
okay so relight i understand the game
has made you pretty popular with your
girls right
yeah it's fun you know i've got three
daughters and y'all know like there are
some projects that you do that your
friends and family like really excited
about
but for my daughters elsie millie and
hattie elsie is 12. millie's nine
patty six they've never had something
like this where
they could be that excited and i knew it
was a big deal because elsie now at 12
young beautiful young lady she's
she's texting some friends and so this
boy that i know that kind of has a crush
on her
texted her and and the boy was like hey
uh is that your dad
on that netflix show floors lava and she
was like yeah
and he said cool have you seen all the
shows and she
reads that text to me like he asked if i
saw the shows dad
of course i saw the shows what how am i
supposed to answer
and it was this incredible moment
because i thought like that's my girl
you bet did i see the shows it's my dad
of course i saw the show so it's really
fun don't
i mean some kids don't watch their
parents stuff they're like over it
well and let's be honest i've not been
the hit factory
kelly that that you have so i don't like
i'm sure after like oh mom's got another
yeah
they don't care what i do but one day
like one day there's gonna be this real
thing where they're like oh my gosh
yeah your mom's a hit maker app she
she's like midas touch this is amazing
so for right now it's pretty cool for
the kids to have that kind of
thing you know my dogs watch all of my
things
yes huge faces
all right wait olivia so you're as
competitive as i am i hear
um i'll bet you know i might know a
little bit more about superheroes
hosting i know you played superhero but
i was just wondering if you want to play
a little game to find out because
rutledge kind of challenged us a minute
ago i'm just saying
i'm really bad i have like a horrible
memory with these things
okay that's perfect i'm actually
slightly terrified as well because while
i do love the movies and i love like
growing up with them i don't know that
i'm going to nail this so watch us both
epically fail together
wait rutledge will you help us out by
refereeing uh
yeah you know what i've i've had a
minute just then i just wrote a few
questions all right yeah i'm back with
olivia munn and floor is lava host
rutledgewood we're going to play a
special version of
rutledge's game show right now this is
called what is it called let's show your
sign
show your song it's
[Music]
all right here's how it works rutledge
will read each of us a trivia question
one at a time if we get it right we get
a point but
if olivia or i get it wrong we have to
take a shot
of lava or a sip aka hot sauce
that we have here at our zoom desks and
whoever gets the most
points wins so and in honor of olivia
and me because i love superheroes too
all the trivia questions are super
super hero themed so here we go are you
guys ready
this feels so official like that was
absolute official game show
read that was so impressive lynch i'm in
it okay
here we go okay question one this one's
for olivia
which film started off the current
marvel superhero
universe iron man oh
that's correct she's on the board
i'm just going to drink my water not the
hot sauce
oh show off okay man i love olivia munn
okay a little bit of a flex there here
we go question two
kelly uh what weapon does thor
carry oh a hammer you know what i'm
gonna take a little bit of my milk
olivia oh wow
i'm lactose intolerant me too mine's
almond
oh boy if you don't get
if you already get right yeah let's say
y'all better get right with oatley that
stuff's amazing here we go question
three
uh olivia olavia uh how many actors have
played the role of
peter parker slash spiderman
in the live action films he'll be
macquarie
andrew garfield the new british
kid he's british right is that really is
that really important right now
[Laughter]
you don't know how my mind works let's
just assume then yes he's british
there was well those are the first three
but then there's more after that i'm
gonna say
live action is tv and everything it's
gotta be more let's say it's gonna be
like 10 or
15 or 20 or 15 um 10
and 12. you are totally taking this hot
sauce chick three
drink up it was three yes you had it
then you
doubted yourself i the thing i didn't
know he was tricking you on if that new
one
the animated one counted because i
didn't well i didn't know if you meant
like
back in the in the in the like in the in
the olden days
was there another one i would have given
you four but 15 is just it's not
that's not four's neighbor okay i love
your vat of hot sauce
by the way this came from you kelly
clarkson i know i don't okay well i love
that we
sent you the pandemic ver the costco
version of
like we wanted you to not run out in the
next days we got this
sent me shot glasses drink up oh wow
boy just something slow is this enough
you can literally sip because i
literally have to sing after this
i can't i can't shoot this ah you're
fine
there it is chase it okay kelly are you
ready
i'm ready here we go question number
four how did the fantastic
four get their super powers
um i'm gonna say i mean i've seen kind
of a poster
for it so um i'm gonna say from
from the environment something happened
with the environment
okay okay yes you've got something
that's very vague can you roll that
ball down the hill a little more okay
that was a good guess wow
um something happened with the
environment there was there was um
there was an explosion could be yes
because of something
and and and there were scientists
testing stuff and it got out
and then it hit them and then they were
affected
and then they they blew up and every
check with the judges olivia do you buy
most of that
i mean i'm going to say i'm going to say
them i think that she did a pretty good
job and i would give it to her i believe
that they crashed back to earth
cosmic or space radiation so really you
were there
i felt like you did you basically there
was a thing and then there was a problem
with it
that that feels that's integrity kelly
that's what you're feeling right now
i appreciate it you need a pickle back
you need a pickle
i'm going to start a nickelback cover
band with pickles called pickleback
that means all right i'm going to try it
i know uh olivia we only got questions
time for a couple more here we go uh
which superhero does bruce banner
transform into
i know this one of course you do because
you missed the last one
you gotta know this one no pressure
no pressure he was a just assume he was
a tax accountant
and then sometimes he got really just
different
turnt as the kids say i don't know why
bruce lauren is
bruce banner um did you see that oh yeah
no i know it's hulk
there we go because i don't know why but
hey
you got i know i took some milk for you
because my mouth is still on fire
all right kelly we're gonna we're gonna
give you one last one who i'm gonna i'm
gonna pick
uh what would groot say if he wanted to
tell you
he was hungry fruit exactly
he would just say groot because that's
all he says that's his one word
i am group question i love guardians of
the galaxy i love i love them
anyway that was awesome olivia well done
my mouth is on fire
still so you win you guys are so awesome
thank you so much for playing
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel
please don't make me keep going